acting homeland security secretary under
president trump and also chairman of the
america first policy institute's center
for homeland security and immigration
chad wolfe joins me now chad happy new
year to you thanks for joining us um
according to cvp thank you so according
to cbp's own numbers we've seen for nine
months now
encounters at the southern border with
migrants trying to cross into the united
states has topped 160 000 this
culminated last week excuse me last
month with a total of 175
000 encounters tell us what that means
to you
well what we see month after month since
the biden administration took over in
january of 21 is historic numbers each
month they get worse and worse as far as
the illegal apprehensions across that
border and what that means is that both
their messaging and the policies that
they're putting in place to address the
border security crisis is not working
they need a new strategy they need a new
approach
and we continue to see these record high
numbers because what the cartels and
what the illegal migrants know is that
if they cross that border odds are that
they will remain in the united states
for years as their immigration court
proceedings continue and that's that's
the issue here and that's what the biden
administration needs to address they're
trying to do it with the remain new
mexico program even though they don't
agree with it and they're going to the
supreme court to try to get it
overturned so messaging is a problem and
their policies are a problem
so cbp also tells us now it's not only
um
the challenge of dealing with record
numbers of migrants coming across the
border it's record amounts of fentanyl
that are also breaking through certain
sectors of the u.s southern border
that's almost equally dangerous right
well absolutely and the two go hand in
hand because what we see
the cartels are making the numbers
upwards to 14 million dollars a day
smuggling and trafficking human beings
in record numbers across the border and
what they're doing with the proceeds of
that are putting it back into their
illicit enterprise and so you're seeing
record numbers of illicit narcotics
fentanyl opioids and the like coming
across that border in numbers that we
have never seen before and we're only
apprehending just a small percentage of
it usually at ports of entry and we
don't know really what's coming between
the ports of entry in the middle of the
desert and elsewhere because our agents
our border patrol agents are no longer
on the border doing that national
security mission they're instead back in
border patrol facilities processing
these large numbers of migrants and we
need them on the line we need them
apprehending individuals and illegal
narcotics coming across that border a
lot of the border hawks and you listen
to them and they like to list over and
over again
this multitude of threats right
drug traffickers human traffickers would
be terrorists apprehended at the border
like that saudi gentleman with ties to
yemeni terrorists we heard about last
week i don't hear a lot of people though
really doing the hard work of
prioritizing those threats so that
us ordinary americans can sort of
understand
what we need to be concerned about
what do you see as the top threat right
now
well sure the threat is
what we see is you know the record
numbers of individuals coming across
that border a lot of them are families
and a lot of them are minors but not all
and so embedded in this flow and what we
saw during the trump administration was
embedded in the flow are your public
security concerns the ms-13 gang members
and other criminals your national
security threats and the like and again
those numbers are not huge but they
don't need to be huge you don't need
hundreds of thousands of ms-13 members
and other national security and would-be
terrorists coming across you only need a
small handful coming across that border
and that's what border patrol that's
their job day in and day out is to
patrol that border and make sure those
individuals don't come in the country
and if they do are apprehended but what
we see month after month because of this
historic numbers is we're seeing upwards
of 50 to 60 000 godaways these are
individuals never apprehended by border
patrol because we don't have enough
agents and enough resources because the
system is overwhelmed by the number of
folks coming across that border and that
is the concern the concern is having
those criminals and other national
security threats get by the border
patrol not apprehended and not
interviewed and not
come into contact with it all now the
state of texas is making moves on its
own
they've broken ground on this border
wall that they are
planning to
move forward with completely on their
own they're doing it without funding
from the fed but they're also doing it
without any kind of authorization from
the fed
is this something your
supportive of is it something that could
be replicated in other states and
is this sort of
okay
well unfortunately it's something that
governor abbott's having to do on his
own look this is a national security
issue and the federal government dhs
needs to be leading the charge here but
what we see from the biden
administration is not building new
border wall
again withdrawing from the remaining new
mexico program canceling a number of
policies that work and so governor
abbott governor ducey and others along
the border are looking at the border
seeing that it's wide open and saying
how do i protect my constituents how do
i protect texans and one thing that they
do and they listen to are the border
patrol agents along that border that say
we need effective
infrastructure we need that impedance
and denial so that if someone trying to
cross the border gives us time to get to
that location and to apprehend them and
that's what texas is doing as they build
that border wall so should they be
expending state resources no the federal
government should be doing it but i
don't know that governor abbott really
has a choice at this point his his rgv
which is the rio grande valley is ground
central for this surge and he needs to
protect texans and other communities
along that border and he's doing
everything that he can governor abbott
has already pledged close to two billion
dollars to the project um so we'll
certainly be tracking that chad wolfe
thanks for joining us today we
appreciate it
all right great thank you